je m'appelle adrien nos gars et j'ai 33
ans je suis streamer et les gens me
connaissent sur internet sous pseudonyme
zerator sur son rivage vous attend votre
aventure la france a repris le contrôle
de ce territoire très bien excellent en
2017 avec mon pote dash on a créé un
événement qui s'appelle i even je
déclare la cérémonie le lit et veut-il
son événement ouvert messieurs allez sur
vos live c'est parti daisy events et
plusieurs streamer switch qui se
rassemblent dans une pièce pendant trois
jours et qui font du contenu de manière
tout à fait normale comme ils le
feraient tous les autres jours sauf que
cette fois il appelle les gens à donner
de l'argent pour une cause ont choisi
chaque année vous avez moins de 30 ans
et vous venez de créer un événement qui
arrêté vient de récolter 1 million
d'euros comment vous sentez
vous lever 5 millions d'actions
en 2021 on a choisi action contre la
faim et on a levé un peu plus de 10
millions d'euros grâce à la générosité
des gens qui nous ont regardés
[Musique]
étant donné que c'était une grosse somme
récoltée action contre la faim a décidé
d'investir cet argent dans plusieurs
projets dans les pays dans lesquels ils
étaient présents comme ici en république
centrafricaine où ils ont investi plus
de 1,2 million d'euros dans des centres
hospitaliers qui était déjà créés ou
alors dans des formations agricoles et
de la pédiatrie
[Musique]
on arrive aux complexes hospitaliers
universitaires pédiatriques de bangui où
on va voir un petit peu les actions
d'action de la fin
[Musique]
là c'est la salle pour en faire des
tests d'appétit les enfants encore les
enfants viennent maintenant les tests
d'appétit
c'est la pâte qu'on donne un enfant avec
une autre chanson poids une quantité
canton à l'enfant pour que l'enfant
prenne si l'enfant arrive à tout plan
sécurité s'imposent 6 panneaux formant
qui nécessite l'hospitalisation
si le test est négatif leur ai dit qu'il
faut à mon enfant est très malade et
c'est un enfant quand tu dois me tenir
ici pour commencer le traitement par le
let et la pitié
on a un cervidé chaise intensif qui
reçoit les malades plus critique et donc
on les met ici ce qu'un service avec
trois salles et 16 lits ce sont des
enfants qui présentent un tableau de
matisse à aiguë sévère mais type
prochain avec le sud est et puis ce sont
les lésions cutanées qui sont typiques
des malades souffrent du kw/h pas
là maintenant on en moi de malades et
c'est beaucoup plus pendant la saison
pluvieuse qu'on a avec le palu avec le
no pâtisser là mais non ça c'est mon
salon non c'est pas tout le temps il y
avait pu voir la dépouille du pic
ce sont les enfants qu'on a de la phase
2 chez des temps si on les voit là on a
un peu stabilisé et on en voit ici et là
par exemple on est en train de faire le
test l'appétit c'est un enfant qui
n'arrive pas à prendre les leurs la
migration des glacis et maintenant si en
est là ce sont les enfants tendance à
arracher la scène c'est pour cela qu'on
l'a immobilisé ses doigts pour pêcher de
de tirer la santé
le plus souvent ce sont des malades qui
nous arrive dans des caveaux montre tout
sourire et pour ça c'est un peu
difficile d y en a qu'on a pu récupérer
mais il y en a qui y seront
si tout est plein il ya combien de jeux
à 90 il a 90 90 voilà servis des 90
voilà mai à doha au moment depuis que
c'est plein c'est vraiment plein oui
[Musique]
bon honnêtement c'est
évidemment incroyable de voir
des actions concrètes de ce qu'on a pu
faire avec le zii event après c'est pas
toujours facile hein forcément je vous
cache pas que il y avait des choses plus
dures à voir que d'autres on a un peu
hésité à vous montrer en fait c'est
toujours compliqué pour nous la limite
entre le truc moralisateur misérabiliste
on en a vu beaucoup d images comme ça
mais je pense que c'est quand même
important de vous les montrer parce que
c'est vraiment la réalité du terrain
d'autant qu'ici c'est vraiment un centre
dans lequel on arrive beaucoup à soigner
sur les 10 millions et plus qu'on a
récolté sur le lit event ya à peine 10 %
qui a été invitée investi environ en
république centrafricaine pour nous
c'est qu'une toute petite partie la
collecte est pour eux ça va leur
permettre d'être financés là par exemple
2 avril jusqu'à décembre c'est à dire
que s'ils avaient pas eu ici event
l'hôpital aurait arrêté de fonctionner
jusqu'à retrouver une source de
financement donc encore une fois bravo
vous j'ai pas précisé non plus mais ici
tout est gratuit c'est à dire que les
parents viennent et ils sont ils sont
pris en charge intégralement avec leurs
enfants
où
bonjour bonjour moi c'est gaudi enchanté
adrien
saint-affrique merci est tenu à vous
recevoir parce que ce que j'ai fait est
très grand il en envoie un message
simple à
l'humanisme d'être dessus de tout ça
l'être humain d'être dessus de tout ça
nous étions à un moment où
on se posait des questions sur les
financements avec des risques que avec
la l'épuisement de ses moyens quand on
revient à la case de départ et en face
ce qui je parle de l'union européenne
avec qui on avait discuté
nous ont dit mme écoutez vous êtes dans
un pays où la priorité va
va à la sécurité la santé et est intacte
et dans ces conditions négatives
on était là quand ces jeunes sont
arrivés de nulle part je peux dire pour
résoudre ce problème
pour combler ccc l'avenir et quand on
voit ce que des jeunes comme ça font ça
doit interpeller ceux qui vont utiliser
ces moyens là
il faut qu'on fasse du serveur avec moi
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est devenu une
force les gens ils sont trés sa livrée
très satisfait de voir que effectivement
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est pas pour rien
il ya des gens parfois ils disent eh ben
voilà je vais peut-être mangé un peu
moins ce mois-ci ou à faire peut-être
acheter un paquet de parents - mais là
je vais donner de l'argent pour quelque
chose de concret à long terme je pense
que ces gens là particulièrement ils
vont être très touchée par toutes ces
images est ce que vous dites il faut
prendre conscience de ça est-ce qu'on
nous dise ce que les gens ne sacrifie ce
que les gens ont fait en amont j'ai les
preuves comme des sauveurs
mais la question c'est mais après eux
et
sa position
toi
on est ici dans la base principale
d'action contre la faim à bangui la
capitale de la république centrafricaine
dans le pays action contre la faim c'est
environ 400 personnes à savoir 380 staff
nat c'est à dire des gens qui ont la
nationalité et qui travaille pour action
contre la faim et environ 30 quarantaine
d'expatriés qui travaillent ici à plein
temps
pourquoi aujourd'hui aston contre la
faim a besoin d'être d'être en
centrafrique alors je sais que c'est une
grande question mais globalement
d'expliquer aux gens ce qui se passe si
et pourquoi vous êtes là bas la
centrafrique qui il faut savoir que
c'est l'avant dernier pays sur indice de
développement humain on parle de plus de
trois millions de personnes dans le
besoin ce qui représente à peu près 60%
de la population ce qui n est pas
négligeable
les infrastructures du pays sont sont au
plus bas et c'est une crise qui seul qui
durait se répète depuis des décennies
république centrafricaine est un peu une
crise oubliée ouais donc ça passe par
des hauts et des bas on continue tu veux
dire politiquement par exemple voilà il
ya quand c'est vraiment l'urgence ça
fait un peu la une il ya des bailleurs
il ya de l'argent qui vient et puis
petit à petit on retombe dans les
travers de la crise il ya moins de
bailleurs moins d'argent
qu'est ce que c'est globalement alors
acf en centrafrique où travaillent dans
plusieurs secteurs où travaillent dans
la santé la nutrition ouais la santé
mentale et les pratiques de soins l'eau
l'hygiène et l'assainissement et enfin
la sécurité alimentaire donc dans chaque
secteur en fait c'est des secteurs sous
jacent de la malnutrition ont parlé
aussi des formations fait des formations
agricoles je crois pour les pour des
familles en centrafrique et nous nous
parlait ça notamment pour du coup avec
les fronts du g20 ça permet aussi de
maintenir un centre de formation on est
en activité dans le nord à bossangoa où
c'est un peu une école pour
l'agriculture
à
5-0 vite quitte à poser champ pour
caspar un toit s'est lâché a plutôt fait
ramasser la delta victoire à lima
[Musique]
je suis dit aussi ralph a cédé nom de
code pour pas dévoiler de noms à la
radio c'est de la sécurité tout
simplement c'est pas ce pas pour rigoler
quand même dans un pays où il faut
prendre un peu de mesures de sécurité
parfois
[Musique]
donc ici on est à l'unité de nutrition
thérapeutique ambulatoires donc c'est un
endroit où les gens ne restent pas plus
de douze heures il n'y a pas de prise en
charge les gens restent c'est aussi
toute une partie maternité et c'est l'un
des seuls points maternité de bangui de
la capitale et donc du pays c'est un
centre qui a été fondée par la croix
rouge il ya de ça quelques années qui
est entretenue par médecins sans
frontières belgique et par action contre
la faim
ici là pour apporter un appui et soutien
ce coloris un soutien moral pour ces
enfants là et pour ses accompagnateurs
dès que ces enfants sont mal le p
automatiquement sa touche le haut niveau
et si tu sais pas pourquoi on apporte
ses tapis là sur le plan sentimental et
de même les accompagnant un enfant qui
est mal noté la compagnie est vraiment
dans un état des arts a donc il faut
toujours accompagné cette enfilade
ici on voit des gens qui arrivent et qui
amènent leurs enfants des consultations
pédiatriques pour savoir si leur enfant
a besoin d'un traitement ou alors si le
traitement qu'ils ont eue fonctionne ça
peut être de la nutrition ou des
médicaments s'il se trouve qu'il ya des
complications avec un enfant ou même un
parent en fait il n'est pas il reste pas
ici ça c'est vraiment une première unité
de traitement il est envoyé directement
soit au centre pédiatrique soit à
l'hôpital général qui est en face c'est
tout aussi important ici bien sûr parce
que c'est aussi un premier contact en
fait c'est un premier contact avec le
personnel de santé parfois c'est la
première fois que des gens voient un
médecin dans cet endroit que ce soit
pour leurs enfants pour eux mêmes donc
c'est évidemment comme un genre de
médecins de ville sauf que c'est un
centre évidemment puisque c'est
compliqué d'avoir des cabinets partout
dans une ville comme bambi
il est un peu malin il à
l'impressionnant
la couleur de bella devient jour
séjour
voulait de les mixer l'antibiotique ou
face à 6 en attendant de quoi le jeu
comme ça on peut différer la
raconter ce qui nous suit
ses enfants qu'ils ont pris en charge
ici habituellement on arrive à
l'équilibré est allé propres sites et
leurs enfants qui prenaient le relais en
action les parents de ces enfants sauf
qu'en fait ce programme s'est arrêté et
des flux en art on a commencé à voir des
enfants bien équilibrée qui reviennent
parce que la prise en charge au niveau
social pose problème
mais là tu vois
c'est rigolo de se dire que le premier
event on l'a fait dans mon salon le 2e i
even c'était dans un garage
est bon maintenant c'est un peu plus
gros mais de se dire que ça amène
à voir des choses comme ça et à pouvoir
aider des gens d'un pays quasiment
entiers et on représente un peu chaque
petits donateurs même si je sais que
tout le monde n'a pas fait un don
forcément rapport avec la cause bien sûr
mais ça fait partie aussi du jeu dans le
n'zi events et on est venu aussi pour
leur montrer que ça sert à quelque chose
et que c'est important de
se souvenir que le zii event c'est
d'abord un combat humanitaire
avant d'être la clownerie mais on aime
bien faire les deux
alexandre et moir ont fait chaque année
des collectes de d'argent en faisant du
jeu vidéo sur internet et en se filmant
en train de faire ça de gens nous
regardent et en fait on crée du
divertissement et on invite les gens à
donner de l'argent pour une cause l'an
dernier c'était action contre la faim et
on a récolté un peu plus de 10 millions
d'euros donc ça a été une somme énorme
même pour nous c'est une somme vraiment
énorme d'habitude on fait pas autant on
a aussi travaillé que la croix rouge
avec médecins sans frontières avec
l'institut pasteur organise que vous
connaissez je pense
et voilà c'est la première fois par
contre pour se déplace dans un pays et
pour voir les actions qui sont qui
résulte de la collecte donc on est très
content d'être venu merci beaucoup
encore une fois bravo pour ce que vous
faites
mais c'est vrai que l'argent qu'on aime
c'est important mais si vous étiez pas
là et servir à rien donc c'est grâce à
ces fonds que l'intervention va
continuer jusqu'au 31 décembre on espère
que d'ici la fin de l'année d'autres
donateurs vont se manifester pour que
toutes ces actions entreprises par la
chambre de la faim au niveau du ch ipd
où les agents de santé font un travail
extraordinaire discontinuer au bénéfice
des enfants de
la république centrafricaine vous
remercier pour ce que vous avez fait
pour notre pays si vous avez beaucoup
les enfants sont en quête ce que vous
avez foulé m'a montré en tout cas je
vous ai finalement c'est vrai que cette
année encore plus que les autres années
on peut le dire le yémen sauve des vies
on en est là c'était déjà vrai les
années avant même la première année
c'était déjà vrai avec save the children
même si l'événement portait pas le nom
de the event mais
c'est encore plus vrai maintenant qu'en
plus les moyens déployés peuvent être
colossaux grâce à la taille de la
collecte donc ouais c'est faut que les
gens se rendent compte que c'est
incroyable c'est vraiment incroyable